are you looking to kill time for The
Legend of Zelda for the Wii U comes out
well lucky for you an HD remake of the
legend of zelda twilight princess is
coming to the Wii U following rumors
last month and the steady train of Zelda
franchise remakes Nintendo today
confirmed that the Gamecube / we cross
over title twilight princess is coming
to Wii U dub Twilight Princess HD the
game will have updated graphics and it's
being headed up by Australian developer
Tantalus but the updated version of
twilight princess will include more than
just a visual upgrade it'll come
packaged with a newly announced wolf
link amiibo the game will also support
the other Legend of Zelda amiibo
characters from the smash bros roster
such as Toon Link and Ganondorf while he
didn't include specifics Nintendo of
America president Reggie fils-aime a
said that progress saved to meebo from
twilight princess would carry over in
some way to the upcoming the legend of
zelda game on the Wii U Twilight
Princess HD is due out March 4 2016 and
is available for pre-order now since
2016 is the 30th anniversary of The
Legend of Zelda franchise we can expect
even more announcements and news next
year now that every other console game
has been remade maybe an HD version of
Skyward Sword is on the horizon I just
hope we get more details on the legend
of zelda for Wii U for more news from
the Nintendo Direct and the twilight
princess remake stay tuned to gamespot